السلام عليكم واهلا بكم تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه تسجيلين مصورين اظهر احدهما
اعدام الراهنه الامريكي بيتر بيتر ا سيد
بينما تضمن الاخر صورا لعمليات اعدام
لجنود السوريين في الاثناء رهن الجنرال
مارتن ديمبسي رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه القضاء على تنظيم الدوله في
انهاء الانقسام بين السنه والشيعه نتوقف
مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين الى اي حد
اسهمت رسائل تنظيم الدوله في حمل واشنطن
على اعاده التفكير في اسباب موجه التراب
في الحاله
وماهي الانعكاسات الوحده الاستنتاج واشنطن
بخصوص علاقه التنظيم للصراع الطائفي في
المنطقه
تسجيل ان مصور ان تفهما مسلحي تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه على الانترنيت بحمل
رسائل شديده دمويه لاعداء التنظيم ومن
بينها الولايات المتحده التي كان احد
مواطنيها الضحيه التي يظهرها واحد من
التسجيل ايه الاتجاه المعاكس بعثت
الولايات المتحده على لسان الجنرال مارتن
ديمبسي رئيس هيئه الاركان الامريكيه
المشتركه بعثت رساله الى تنظيم الدوله دعا
فيها لمزيد من الحسم في مواجهه التنظيم
واكد في الوقت نفسه على اهميه انهاء
الانقسام السني الشيعي للقضاء على
ليصلوا ديمسي بغداد من هناك يبشر الرجل
بان الحمله على تنظيم الدوله بدات تؤتي
ثمارها يصف مسلحيها بانهم مجموعه من
الاقسام وان من المهم اظهارهم بانهم ليسوا
قوه لا يمكن قهرها في اليوم التالي تحديدا
ياتي رد التنظيم لقد تم قطع راس الرهينه
الامريكي تاكسين الشاب الذبيح لم يكن عدوا
للاجئين السوريين ترك حياته في انديانا
واسس منظمه خيريه تعنى بشؤون هم قبل عامين
وفي اكتوبر من العام الماضي خطف بينما كان
في طريقه الى مدينه دير الزور
سوريا انذاك اعلن اسلامه اصبح اسمه عبد
الرحمان لكن ذلك لم يحل دون ذبحه بعد نحو
عام بطريقه بدائيه
ذابحه انفسهم بس صورا تتميز باحتراف لا
يخفي لمسلحين في التنظيم وهم يتهيؤون لذبح
جنود سوريين زاويه التصوير تظهرهم اقرب
الى العمال ق منهم الى الاقسام كان الصوره
اريد لها ان ترد على وصف دمت لهم بالاقدام
رغم انها اسقطت على الاغلب في وقت مبكر من
زيارته لبغداد
اللقطات داله هدفها انتاج صوره المسلحين
بعزيمه لا تلين وبادوات قتل بدائيه هي
السكاكين ما يجعل منها اي هذه الصوره
قادره على احداث الصدمه والترويع واشاعتها
في قلوب خصومهم لكن تلك ليست رساله ولا غد
الوحيد على الامريكيين قبل ذلك خرج
البغدادي زعيمهم وكبيرهم وهدد وتوعد وتعهد
بجر الامريكيين للنزول الى الارض حيث
ينتظرهم حتفهم كما قال في الوقت نفسه
تقريبا مثول وزير الدفاع الامريكي امام
الكونغرس وتعهد بدوره بتكثيف الضربات
الجويه رابطا ذلك ب تحسن اداء القوات
العراقيه على الارض على انما تبدو مهمه
عراقيه خالصه التصدي لتنظيم الدوله تظل
ناقصه من دون النجاح في انهاء الانقسام
بين السنه والشيعه قال ذلك الذي كان رئيسه
يستقبل المالكي و يمده بالعون والدعم
انذاك كان السنه العراقي هم ضحايا
الطائفيه المتوحشه للرجل لم يرى
الامريكيون ذلك او لم يريدوا كما تغافل عن
ما يفعله بشار به
فكانت النتيجه تنظيما قطع الرؤوس ويذبح
يقاتل يجتاح ويتوسع
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
السفير علي المتحدث السابق باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن لندن الدكتور غسان
العطيه مدير المعهد العراقي للتنميه
والديمقراطيه نرحب بضيفي الكريمين ابدا من
واشنطن والسفير ادم ايرلي والسؤال الليل
الى اي حد السفير اه اللي تشكل هذه
الرسائل من تنظيم
اولا اداه للضغط على الاداره الامريكيه
واحراج امام الراي العام الامريكي دفعها
اه ربما ل اه الخروج بهذه الطريقه
والتعامل مع اه هذه
الخطوات
لا اعتقد ان عمليه الاعدام هذه تمثل فرقا
كبيره بالنسبه للحكومه الامريكيه
في الاخص فيما يتعلق بها لتنظيم الدوله
والاستراتيجيه الامريكيه ضد هذا التنظيم
ان هذا الامر مريع ومساوي وهو غير انساني
ويمكن ان نستخدم كافه الصفات والعبارات
السلبيه لم صفه لكنه لم يكن غير منتظر
علينا ان نتذكر بان التنظيم الدولي قد
اعدم امريكيين في السابق وقال بانه وتوعد
بانه سيعدم السيد كان سك وبالتالي التنظيم
هي فقط بما قال انه سيقوم به لفتره طويله
هذا هو الامر الاول وبالتالي هذا الامر لن
يكون له اي تاثير على السبل التي ترى بها
الاداره الامريكيه هذا التنظيم ثانيا
الرئيس حدد استراتيجيه لمواجهه تنظيم
الدوله وقد حاولنا في ان نبنيه تحالفا
دوليا شمل دول امن المنطقه مثل قطر
والسعوديه والبحرين والامارات من اجل
مكافحه تنظيم الدوله ومجابهته واعتقد اننا
لدينا خطه جيده لهزيمه ودحر تنظيم الدوله
وبالتالي عمليه الاعدام هذه لن تغير هذا
المسعى ولا ان تؤثر عليه باي حال من
الاحوال ان ما يهم في عمليه هزيمه تنظيم
الدوله ونواصل المجهود وان نواصل خطتنا
هذه الخطه تستغل سنوات عديده من من
الهجمات والجهود اه المنطقه كافه الاطراف
طبعا هذا سيد اليد ان نتعرف على وجهه نظر
اخرى من لندن الدكتور غسان العطيه دكتور
غسان باعتقادك الى اي مدى اه فعليا يمكن
ان تشكل هذه الرسائل اد اه اه ضغط والى اي
مدى التنظيم تنظيم الدوله واحد اصلا
الاثر المحتمل ل اه كل ما يقوم به على
الارض
ما قام به التنظيم الدول الاسلاميه
الرؤوس بهذا الشكل
في واقع ال ان يتحول الى اداه بتوحيد
الراي العام العالمي هو الامريكي ضد هذا
التنظيم فبالتالي السؤال ان هذه الخطوات
قد تثير الرعب بين الناس لكن اعتماد
الترهيب والرعب كاسلوب لاخضاع الاخرين هذه
تاتي ب مردود عكسي بين ابناء المناطق اللي
يتواجد بها التنظيم هذا اسلوب لا يخدم
ولكن بالمقابل الولايات المتحده في
تعاملها بهذا الموضوع يجب ان تكون اكثر
وضوحا في استراتيجيتها استراتيجيه
الولايات المتحده التي اصبحت واضحه تقول
نريد تحالف وهذا يذكرني بالتحالف اللي قام
ب احتلال العراق ويوم امس ذكر الرئيس بوش
في مقابله الماء انهم بالغوا باهميه ذلك
التحالف اليوم كذلك التحالف بالحقيقه هي
الولايات المتحده والتحالف هذا اقناع
الراي العام الامريكي بان هذا راي دولي
وليس راي امريكي فقط الشيء الثاني
اقرار الامريكان نفسهم بان الضربات الجويه
لا تكفي وحدها وانما مطلوب شيء على الارض
الضربات الجويه بالنسبه للتنظيم الدوله
بامكانهم ان يتعايشوا معها من خلال تبني
تكتيكات مختلفه اللجوء الى الخنادق المرور
ليس ب قوافل طويله وانما بسيارات قليله لا
بل حتى البعض اخذ دراجات الهويه الهوائيه
والمشكلات وغير ذلك هذا جانب الجانب
الثاني من
المقاربه الامريكيه هو ان لا بد اعاده
بناء الجيش العراقي الجديد وهذه معركه
كبيره وزياره امس الى بغداد واردين هي
لاستطلاع ماذا حدا بالجيش العراقي الذي
كان يقدر ب مائتين واربعين الف قبل سقوط
الموصل وتلاشي اصبح اقل من مائه وعشرين
الف واليوم يقول القياده الامريكيه تقول
نحن بحاجه الى ثمانين المقاتل عراقي مدرب
تدريب ا حديث او جيدا لكي نسترجع الموصل
وغيرها وهذا يحتاج اشهر واشهر النقطه
الثالثه في المقاربه الامريكيه هو وهي
الاساسيه ان المطلوب مقاربه سياسيه وهي من
خلال تغيير الحكومه باتجاه
الشراكه الشامله السؤال الشراكه الشامله
من احد الاسباب لفقدانها هو المقاربه
الامريكيه للاحتلال العراقي بان تكون انه
الشيعه والسنه والكرد ان ان اقف تحديدا عن
ما ذكرته بخصوص الجنرال جنسي و زيارته
للعراق مع السفير اللي يعني عندما تحدث عن
ضروره انهاء الصراع الطائفي للقضاء على
تنظيم الدوله كيف يمكن فهم هذا التصريح ان
نحن ازاء مراجعه ربما واعاده التفكير في
اسباب التطرف وتامين في المنطقه من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
راي عام او يحاول يحمل سهم ما قال نحن
نريد افعال وهذا صحيح
السفير يعني ساعود
نفس النظره للواقع وهو امر غير الاعتيادي
لكن في جميع الاحوال انا اتفق معها ما
قاله الضيف فيما يتعلق بتصريح جراء بما
يتعلق بين نهايه الطائفيه فهو كان احيلوا
الى الفكره التي قالها الدكتور العطيه وهي
ان الحمله ضد تنظيم الدوله لا يمكنها ان
تنجح على الاطلاق من خلال القوات الجويه
لوحدها
بتنظيم الدوله وتنظيم له قوات كبيره واذا
اردت حره فعليك ان تتحرك من خلال السيطره
على المناطق والمحافظه عليها ولن تستطيع
ان تقوم بذلك من خلال الطائرات او
المروحيات او الطيارات بين الطيارات وانما
تقوم بذلك من خلال جلسات والشروط بين ست
سياتي اولائك المشاهد بالتاكيد لا توفر هم
امريكا وللتحالف وانما العراقيين عليهم ان
نقوم بذلك
ذلك من خلال الجيش العراقي
فقط حتى نضع الامور في نصابها نود الان
بدايه لو تكرمت اه تشخيص الوضع قبل ان
ناتي الى الخطوات التي يجب فعل هاو هنا
سؤالي يعني ما نود ان نعرف يعني الولايات
المتحده من خلال هذه التصريحات التي
اطلقها الجنرال ما الذي تريد ان تقوله في
عليا اه هل نحن امام اعتراف من قبلها بان
اه ربما اه ال ال ال التطرف اه او
الطائفيه هي التي قادت الى هذا التطرف
الذي تشهده المنطقه النادي
حسنا
الطائفيه لعبا دورا مهما في خلقيه الوضع
القائم لماذا لانه هو في عهد نوري المالكي
بين الحكومه العراقيه وبشكل منهج يوم منظم
قامت بقمع اه المكون السني في العراق
وخرجت من الجيش ومن الاستخبارات من
الحكومه واعتقل وهم وعدوهم وكنتيجه لذلك
فان السنه رفضها الحكومه الاتحاديه
وسلطتها لانها رات فيها اه الق معهم
وبالتالي عندما تنتظم الدول او انه استفاد
ولعبه على حاله الاضطراب التي يعيشها
السنه من اجل السيطره عليه
تشير اليها اه فيها اقرار واعتراف
الوقت حولنا الدكتور العطيه يعني ما يعتبر
اقرارا بان الطائفيه قادت الى هذا اه اه
التطرف الذي تعيشه المنطقه اه امر جيد لكن
اه يدور لعبتها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في تكريس هذه الطائفيه تحدث
ضيفنا السفير عن اه الولايات المتحده عفوا
عن حكومه المالكي لكن هذه الحكومه كانت
تلقى الدعم والمؤازره من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه
يا سيدتي الولايات المتحده وهذا اصبح
معلوم للجميع ان غزه في العراق دون تصور
سياسي شامل لما بعد الغزو اسقاط النظام
سهل ولكن الصعوبه ماذا ماذا يحل ما وراء
اعتمدت على صيغه ساذجه والان يعترفوا
بسذاجتها بان بالعراق هناك شيعه وسنه
وكردي فاذا الشيعه مع الامريكان والاكراد
مع الامريكان فالسنه عليهم ان يقبلوا وهذه
الديمقراطيه هذه الصيغه المبسطه السطحيه
تجاهلوا تاريخ العراق في العراق لا يقبل
هذه الطريقه في العراق كان مجتمع مدني
لا تتحكم بها السلطات الدينيه هكذا تاسس
الدوله العراقيه ولكن اللي حصل الاسلوب
الامريكي وجدوا ان الحلفاء بالذات
الاسلاميه الشيعه ولا هم لم يكن لامريكا
وانما الى ال الانتماء الهويه وهي ايران
وبذلك قيل على ان امريكا سلمت العراق الى
ايران ام ولازم المتحده خطاها و مجيء
اداره اوباما تدرك هذا الخطا وتحاول ان
تصحيح ولكن اوباما مشكلته اذا كان الرئيس
بوش اه يقحم نفسه في كل معركه الرئيس
اوباما لا يريد ان يتدخل باي شيء ولم
يتدخل الان الا لما تحول تنظيم الدوله
دعم المالكي وكان واضحا من السياسات
الامريكيه في العراق
هذا صحيح يعني ما اقولها بصراحه على
شاشتكم اه قبل شهرين انا في واشنطن واقول
ان المالكي سيدي البلد الى داهيه من كان
يدافع عنه وهم شخصيات السابقين هم اليوم
يهاجموا المالكي الحقائق كانت معروفه
بالسنتين
لماذا
مهمه جدا الحقائق كانت معروفه يعني هذا ما
اود ان اطرح عليك السفير اه اللي هل يعقل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بكل اجهزتها
الاستخباراتيه بكل مراكز بحثها لن تستشعر
حينها مدى خطوره اللعب على الطائفيه
لايصال اه الاوضاع الى ما وصلت اليه اه ام
انها اه كما تشير ايضا بعض ال ال ال
الاتهامات وبعض التحليلات كانت متعمده في
ذلك
على انا اتفق مع الدكتور العطيه وقد
استخدم كلمه اعتقد انها مهمه للغايه وهذه
العباره هي كلمه السخيفه البعض ينظر الى
في المنطقه البعض في المنطقه ينظر الى
امريكا ويعتقدون
انها تخطط لكل شيء وبكافه التفاصيل
وبالتالي فان اي شيء يحدث هو نتيجه لعمليه
مخططه بعنايه قامت بها امريكا
بكونه كنت اعمل في الحكومه الامريكيه وال
يعني كان علي ان داب على المخططات
الامريكيه يمكن ان اقول لكم ودي صراحه بان
امريكا لا تفهم المنطقه
وانها لا تفكر الامور بالتفاصيل التي
نعتقد او حره عندما تفكر ليست لديها كافه
الاجوبه لانها لا تفهم موضوع القبائل ولا
دور ايران وبالتالي قد اخطانا في الامر
الامر بهذه البساطه
وبالتالي حاله الفوضى التي نشاهدها في
المنطقه حاليا ليست نتيجه لمجهود المتعمد
لخلق الطائفيه والفوضى في المنطقه وانما
هي بالاحرى ثمره ونتيجه عاده بالتفكير في
الامور حتى نهايتها والنتيجه العاده
بالتحقيق الجيد وعدم الاستماع لاصدقائنا
بالمنطقه
الاداره الفتره
نعم
سنعود الى سنعود اليك اه لكن الان مضطرين
فقط
فاصل قصير سنناقش بعدها الانعكاسات
العمليه لهذه الاستنتاجات الامريكيه
الاخيره بخصوص اسباب موجه التطرف في
المنطقه نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
ام
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش الرسائل المتبادله بين واشنطن
وتنظيم الدوله وتطور الفهم الامريكي لقضيه
التطرف في المنطقه نعود مجددا ضيفينا
الكريمين الى لندن والدكتور غسان العطيه
دكتور غسان يعني اه نود ان نقف قليلا عند
اه بعض التعديلات التي اجراها السيد
العبادي اه والمتعلقه باعفاء اه اه لسته
وثلاثين من القيادات في الجيش اه والتي
قيل بانها كانت نتيجه لتوجيهات امريكيه
سفير اللي قال بان امريكا لا تفهم المنطقه
هل يمكن القول الان انها بدات فعليا تفهم
المنطقه هل نحن اه ازاء بدايه عمليه اعاده
توازن طائفي في العراق امنيا قد يسبق او
قد يلحق بعده اه السياسي
سؤالك متعدد الجوانب الواحد بدون شك كما
قال تشرشل على الولايات المتحده انها تقوم
بكل الاخطاء الى انت الى ان تكتشف الطريق
السليم ان قدره الولايات المتحده ان تصلح
اخطائها ناحيه ايجابيه ويجب ان تقدم
الولايات المتحده بامكانها ان تصلح
اخطائها وان سعى بالتحول الامريكي اتجاه
الشان العراقي الان الشيء الاخر ان
التعامل مع العراق بالقطار خط وخطه وببطء
في حاله سرطانيه في العراق لا يفيد ناحيه
ثالثه السؤال الغائب بالطرح الامريكي
بالنسبه ل لتنظيم الدوله والعراق هو ماذا
بعد ماذا بعد بعد الانتحار ال اه تنظيم
الدولي بالضبط هذا السؤال كان يطرح لم
يجيبوا عليها امريكان الفين وسبعه والفين
وسته لما ضربت القاعده في العراق وعمليا
هجمت السؤال ماذا وراء ذلك كانت حقيقه
فراغ كبير واولئك الذين وقفوا ضد القاعده
اهينوا من قبل حكومه المالكي وبالتالي وجد
انفسهم انهم كانوا مرتزقه بد انه يكونوا
شركاء حقيقيين اليوم السؤال ي لم اسمع
الاجابه عنه لا من مسؤول امريكي ولا من
مراكز البحث امريكيه ماذا بعد داعش
قال لي ربما هنا قليلا في هذا الخصوص
تتحدثون عنه
في سوريا
عليكم ان تتذكروا الدوله موجوده في البلد
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه في سوريا والعراق
مختلفه
انا شخصيا لدي سؤال يمثل جوابا لسؤال
دكتور العطيه وهو ليس
متعلقا
وبالاحرى هو ما هو مستقبل العراق وسوريا
كان ليس واضحا بالنسبه لي
بان الدوله الاتحاديه تحديدا دوله العراق
كما
مؤسسه حاليه يمكنها ان تنجو من الصراعات
التي تمر بها حاليا انا شخصيا يصعب على ان
اتصور بان الاكراد سيعودون الى اتحاد
سياسي موجود تحت المالكي يصب على كذلك
نتصور القبائل السنيه في الانبار سيعودون
الى اتحاد سياسي كما كان عليها الوضع قبل
دخول تنظيم الدوله انا شخصيا صاروا الشباب
كبير هي للمنشاه الشيعيه الذين سيسمح ون و
يدربون ويطلقون احرارا من الرقابه في
سوريا بما يعيدنا الى الوضع السابق
وبالتالي السؤال الذي نطرحه هو هل الحكومه
العراقيه الاتحاديه تشريع ان تنجو من
الصراع الجاريه حاليا ونواجهها في العراق
بالنسبه لهذا الحقيقي فيما يتعلق سوريا
الوقت نستفيد الامكان كما معنا دكتور غسان
يعني هذا الاقرار الامريكي باعتقادك هل
سيكون له ما بعده ما الذي يجدر يجدر
بالاداره الامريكيه ان تطلب من العبيد
الخطوات لراب الصدع الان بين السنه
والشيعه بعد ان اقرت في مداخلته
انا اعتقد هذا اكون واضح وصريح هناك مشكله
يجب العراقيين ان يتحمل وها هو يقوم بدور
هم لا يعول على الاخرين هناك مشكله
بالعراقيين بانفسنا انا بتقديري الان ال
ال ال البيت العراقي لم اكثر لم اكثر عرب
العراق وهو عمود الخيمه العراقيه وقسم الى
شيعه وسنه المعركه الان كيف نوحد عرب
العراق توحيد عرب العراق معركه كبيره لانه
يصبح هو التيار العام للطائفيه باسم عرب
العراقي بشكل ثمانين من
هنا هو بالضبط السؤال هل الامريكان سيكون
عقبه امام المساعي لتوحيد عرب العراق انا
اعتقد لا لان هذا لا يظهر مصلحتهم العرب
الاخرين وقعوا بخطا كبير في التعامل مع
العراقي لما تحدثوا عن سنه و سنه وسنه ولم
يقدموا شيء للسنه واليوم اكثر من مليون
ونصف
مهجر
بالتالي بالسياسه العربيه لما كانت فقط
سنه دفعوا الشيعه باحضان ايران الان
المقاربه اللي انا واخرين ندعو الى هو كيف
نجد من العرب الشيعه ومن العرب السنه ما
يوحدهم لا يوحدنا الانتماء للعرب العرب لا
دعني القوميه العربيه ايام زمان وانما
وحده عرب العراق ووحده الاكراد كوحده
الاشوريين كوحده الاخرين
الوضع وعندئذ الاكراد
امره اليك الى الموضوع السوري وقد كنت قد
بدات الحديث عن مثل سوريا ماذا عن خطط
الولايات المتحده في سوريا ولا نبت جليا
البعد الطائفي للازمه في سوريا ماذا عن
يعني ليس فقط من قبل النظام السوري
المتدخلين من الخارج داخل سوريا حزب الله
والجميع يعرف موقف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه منه بدعم الميليشيات العراقيه
هذه الاسئله كلها وجيهه جيده
وانا لا اعتقد بان امريكا لديها اجود على
هذه الاسئله بصراحه
وكما قلنا
اه انه ان المرده قد خرجوا من القمقم
واعتقد اتحدث هنا عن
ارادتها الطائفيه الذين لا يمكن ان يعيدهم
الى الحكم لا اعتقد ان امريكا تسند عيدهم
واتفقوا مع الدكتور العطيه ان هذا امرا
على العرب ان يتعاملوا مع هم بانفسهم لكن
بالنظر الى سوريا اعتقد ان السؤال ساطرحها
عليك انت ما هي السيناريوهات التي يمكن ان
تتصورها والتي تسمح انه بعد مستويات العنف
المرتفعه هذه
ستسمح للمسيح الينا والعلويين والسنه
والدروس ان يتحدوا في
دوله موحده ومن تم جاء تغطي كافه الاراضي
السوريه بالنسبه لهذا الامر غير ممكن
المهمه
لا تملك الاجابات ونحن كنا نود ان تكون
هنالك اجابات ما قيمه اذن ما ذكر الجنسي
من ثروات انهاء هذا الانقسام اه السني
الشيعي
باختصار
انا اتفق مع
الطائفيه لكنه لم يخبرنا كيف سيقوم بذلك
ولم يخبرنا كيف سنحقق ذلك وجهه نظري انه
انهاء الطائفيه سيكون صعبا جدا ما دامت
ايران تواصل تواصل الدعم للحركات الشيعيه
سواء تعلق الامر وحزب الله وسوريا في
العراق او في اي مكان اخر
نحن هنا نتحدث عن اه اه ايجاد حل لهذا
الصراع
لان وقتنا انتهى تماما السفير عدم المتحدث
السابق باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه كنت
معنا من واشنطن والدكتور غسان العطيه كان
معنا من لندن
السلام عليكم
ام